I am telling you it used to be where I
would have to wear my husband's big old
baggy t-shirts when we went to a game
because there was nothing cute for me to
wear and you came in and totally changed
the game tell us why you started the
wild Collective yeah so we started the
wild Collective about a little a little
over three years ago and we started with
you know Vegas's very own uh the Vegas
golden knights so to all the vgk fans we
started a collection with them and
really from that collection is really
what sent us into overdrive we just
started taking over every single Sports
league and coming out with product
across teams all over the country really
and they started to come to us which was
the really exciting part is that we were
we weren't in a position now we're going
after people they were coming to us and
saying hey we saw what you did with the
Knights can you create these custom cool
collections for us and from that we
basically gone across every League now
so we're licensed across MLB NBA uh WNBA
so our Aces that's what I was looking
for yeah
Aces I love this shirt where can we get
the wild Collective at all the stadiums
so we're yeah we're pretty much in every
Stadium across the country for NFL
um NBA we're launching 17 teams this
fall so that's literally in a week uh
we're in MLB stadiums across um across
the country as well as NHL we do local
license so we operate a ton of different
venues across the country even in Canada
and you really have taken the fashion
game up like 10 notches check out this
Raiders uh jacket and this is something
I mean a lot of your stuff is for women
but I could see guys wearing some of
these yeah so we actually do a lot of
unisex pieces as well um so we have a
couple pieces that are definitely like
obviously this Raiders sequin tea you
can get in stadium and on our site um
definitely more of a woman's piece
probably oh I know I could rock that you
never know but then we also have like
really amazing unisex pieces this is our
Raiders band tea that we created
exclusively for the Raiders this is a
stadium exclusive piece you brought up
something about the Cowboys you have a
huge Cowboys collection why don't we
show some of these cool things so
Cowboys is really interesting um you
actually have to get a special license
to work with the Cowboys and we were
lucky enough to get the opportunity so
we developed an entire Cowboys
collection for them men's women's and
unisex pieces
Cowboy contingency here in Las Vegas
yeah there's a lot of cowboy fans here
which I love I mean that's what's so fun
about sports right everyone has their
team everyone has you know teams that
they grew up with and teams that they've
adopted obviously my husband and I we
didn't have a team being from Vegas so
we adopted the Raiders as our team on
the NFL side and I hear your big Broncos
fans I am that's where I grew up in
Denver and they're playing the Raiders
this weekend so I brought a couple
pieces to show you oh my God so we have
a ombre Puffer that we did I want to try
this one this is so cute this is oh my
gosh and you're selling this at you're
not selling the the gear for the Broncos
here in town all right not in town no
man um but this is another piece our
Chenille um patch crop
um these two pieces are actually going
to be available on fnatic so what's
really cool about the wild Collective is
we have exclusive collections all across
every level you can think of so we have
exclusive collections we sell the
Fanatics we have exclusives on our
website and then we have exclusives with
the stadiums across the country so
depending where you go you can find
these cool and unique pieces that you
can't get anywhere else look stylish and
just feel stylish and represent your
team I love it website again uh we are
thewildco.com and there's more Vegas
golden knights pieces coming out
literally T-minus like two weeks so get
excited for that there's a few more
Raiders pieces coming out as well oh
yeah we have some some varsity sweaters
coming out
um
this weekend yeah there you go
I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna take the
Raiders because I'm biased
um but you know we'll see how how it
plays out all right well I'll bet you a
jacket for that yeah okay I'll totally
bet you jacket all right thank you so
much